noah cyrus is getting real about her
struggles with substance abuse and how
she made the decision to change her life
for the better
in a new interview with rolling stone
the singer opens up about her addiction
to xanax which she says began when she
was 18. she tells the mag quote my
boyfriend at the time was the first
person that gave me a xanax and it
became a way for us to bond i think i
wanted to be what he wanted and what he
thought was cool and what everybody was
doing while noah doesn't mention the
boyfriend by name we do know she was
dating rapper lil xan at the time who
since rebranded as diego everybody loves
the chemistry you know what i mean like
it just works you know
got a lot of feelings for her
okay so are we in love like what's
happening yes of course obsessed with
him
he's my best friend
but in late 2018 the two split and noah
spilled to e.t that she learned a lot
from their time together i learned a lot
about relationships in the past two
years coming out of one that i was in
for two years that
you know
there's obviously like ups and downs to
relationship and
i also struggle with heavy anxiety and
depression and that's pretty hard noah
also admits she was constantly
surrounded by people with easy access to
the pills and recalls a dark time when
she nearly fell asleep during a tv
interview quote i was completely nodding
off and falling asleep and unable to
keep my head up or keep my eyes open
because i was so far gone it just kind
of becomes this dark pit bottomless pit
by the time the pandemic hit in 2020
noah's struggles were at their worst so
much so that they got in the way of her
getting to say goodbye to her
grandmother who died later that year
that's when noah says she made the
decision to get help like noah just take
a time to take the time to work on
yourself and make yourself happy now the
singer says she's been in recovery for
nearly two years
but it was music that really seemed to
dig noah out of the pit she fell into i
never
[Music]
she channeled her feelings into lyrics
and began working on her first album the
hardest part which is set to release on
september 16th
[Music]
music's played a big part of noah's
entire life but especially last year
when she nabbed a nomination for best
new artist at the grammys i'm trying to
keep i'm trying to remember that i like
how
special this is for me for every single
artist here that we each need to
personally recognize
that we all need to just live in this
moment and recognize that like
we did that we made the music we got us
to this point and that's just something
that like i am so grateful for and
i'm just so blessed to be here and as
noah navigates her recovery she says
she's in no way trying to be a
spokesperson for it quote i myself am
just going through it and figuring it
out i wake up in the morning and i'm
able to look in the mirror and go on
about my day without hating myself i'm
able to comfort myself and nurture
myself